[Music]
[Laughter]
here we go this episode of
congratulations is brought to you by
cash
[Music]
two or three weeks ago you've got no
idea unless you are a in my you you have
access to my app which you can download
at the app store because I'm live and I
go live babies I go live when I do my my
shows on my app and so you don't know
that unless you unless you have that so
maybe I'm talking about stuff two three
weeks ago but whatever it doesn't
[ __ ] matter because you're gonna just
kind of have fun with it no matter what
and you're here for me babies and I'm
here for you I'll be in let's see Santa
Barbara Riverside San Diego California
Foxwoods Connecticut Bethlehem
Pennsylvania Rochester New York Detroit
Michigan and then Minneapolis to tape my
special Tampa Florida I got a bunch of
these shows coming up so Hollywood
Florida El Paso Texas Houston Texas
that's where they'll that's where I'll
be my babies that's where I'll be and do
you know why because life [ __ ] rips
dude you know what it always surprises
me how much people like inspirational
[ __ ] on Instagram or at just period
really I mean it's a whole reason why
that [ __ ] place was a was able to be
something in the mall member that place
called whatever it was called like
impressions or whatever the [ __ ] you
roll by it and it would have pictures of
it would have the framed picture of a
whale's tail and it'll be like
perseverance or whatever what the
[ __ ] was a call doesn't even it doesn't
matter at all but I will tell you this I
got my shirt on with my sunglasses on
and a shirt with my face with my
sunglasses on and the reason why is
because dude I'm features too bright so
wear your sunglasses today dude people
cuz people because let's be you know
let's [ __ ] because I'm inspirational
man I'm inspirational dude I can't help
it it feels good life I told you life
rips it does dude but it rips but it's
also life is hot so I'm gonna turn the
fan on yeah so that's that's what Jets
what's up dude anyway I got my [ __ ]
sunglasses on cuz it's so goddamn bright
dude when I look ahead I can't help it
I'm in Albuquerque I'm still back and
forth and he's [ __ ] still back and
forth in Albuquerque he can't help it
cuz he's doing a movie he's doing a
movie and it's really fun and it's
really [ __ ] hot and then the fan
doesn't work so that's great dude yes
the fair doesn't work and it's plugged
in oh because [ __ ] one fire kicked it
out when he was setting up yes the plug
[ __ ] kicked out because when one fire
was setting up he [ __ ] hit it with
his dumb shin yes dude [ __ ] yes we're
starting off hot and sweaty [ __ ] yes
[ __ ] thing back in and then I gotta
start it technically yes
good thing my sunglasses are on dude I
don't want to get cataracts you
understand dude I went to the doctor the
other day and I was like doc what's
going on my eyes he goes like this
cataracts and I'm like why
and he goes have you been out in the Sun
a lot and I go no he says well what the
[ __ ] and I left and he goes like this
I'm at a loss and I'm like well what the
[ __ ] do I do dude usually the doctors
like take to these come in the morning
but he didn't do that
so I got ice left out in [ __ ]
went back to another doctor got a second
opinion he's like I don't know what the
[ __ ] to do dude I think you're not gonna
give me two of these to [ __ ] calm you
in the morning next time and it goes
like this I don't know what to do dude
and then they both called me [ __ ]
about a week later and they go like this
dude I didn't know who you were I didn't
know who you were when you came in I'm a
new year maybe you dabbled in comedy or
whatever the [ __ ] but then they said
guess what I know who you are now
and it's because you were on my TV and I
go what and I go like yeah I saw caught
you in some stuff on Netflix like
writing some stuff you know just on TV
on network TV am i and I'm like he
doesn't network to I go eat and I go
yeah and he says I think that it might
be the cataracs might be from your
future because it's too bright so now I
wear these [ __ ] sunglasses and guess
what the cataracts went away and not
many people will honestly make up a
whole [ __ ] story on their podcast
that isn't true and [ __ ] tell it to
you because you can go to other podcasts
for the news you can go to other
podcasts for [ __ ] interviews but
there is one podcast that gives you a
[ __ ] silly goddamn goose time and
that's it dude that is it man if you're
coming here for info if we're coming
here for interviews if you're coming
here for other [ __ ] other than a silly
goose time and that's it
then dude as they say you're in the
wrong neighborhood one time I was shot
at do it
and that's real [ __ ] I was walking to a
[ __ ] girl's house this was so long
ago man I was walking to a girl's house
and when I got there she was like it's a
bad neighborhood and I was like it's
gonna be fine dude cuz chicks are always
like it's a bad neighborhood and it's
not you know because they're chicks but
when you get a real beefy [ __ ] dude
with shoulders that they film Lord of
the Rings on I parked [ __ ] two blocks
away just to make a point
I'm crossing over the [ __ ] Street I'm
taking I you know I parked parallel and
perpendicular to her house and as I
cross the street I hear
and then and I go what tough [ __ ] and
then I go oh I was shot at uh-huh and
then ran ran like a [ __ ] [ __ ] to her
house oh yeah then we hook up yes was it
extra good because I got shot at yes
still in the back of my head it was i
sad for her because you looked at yes
that still sport yes did she move
probably she doesn't learn more probably
not don't think about it every now and
yes did i block it out now anyway dude
sporting and bad neighborhoods is way
hotter cuz you never know what's gonna
happen to it and we know that next why
would i even talk about that cuz it's so
[ __ ] obvious dude um yeah dude so you
come here for a silly goose goddamn time
and if anyone else tells you that you go
to a [ __ ] another podcast for a silly
goose time bro
get out of here other podcasts and
[ __ ] [ __ ] they could have a silly
goose time but you come here for the
real silly goose time dude anyway man
I'm chilling dude I'm back in LA for
[ __ ] two days to do this podcast just
so I can get it out there and and and I
did a show at The Comedy Store at the
Laugh Factory and Comedy Store and I
talked about the Cookie Monster on stage
for [ __ ] I don't even know why and it
wasn't good and it's okay dude because
alive reps for [ __ ] sake just drank
some water dude but yeah um man if
somebody didn't like me and they heard
this but they thought we know what I'll
give him I'll give his podcast one shot
and they turned on this episode they
would hate me extra I'll tell you that
much that's for sure but it's fine dude
yeah my [ __ ] new friend Matthias in
on the movie he gets more German by the
second he said feets the other day hat
but you know he he was like he's
becoming a really good friend of mine
and I forgot why I brought him up but oh
yeah he really liked [ __ ] when I
talked about him on podcast um he's the
nicest guy man I feel like Germans are
extra nice because of what happened you
know I mean I'm not gonna mention it but
you know what I'm talking about
know what I mean you know what I'm
talking about right you know what I mean
rhymes with [ __ ] bit ler that you
know but you did the math right like I'm
not gonna say it but you get it I'm a
lips chap yes is it cuz I was a nerd
Albuquerque for two weeks yes dude of
course it is do my lips get chapped to
the same place yeah dude do I wake up in
the morning and then sometimes look in
the mirror and my [ __ ] mouth is
bleeding like Amazon be yeah yeah
[ __ ] did you see I can't even tell
you how much I thought about Kid Rock
tweeting to Taylor Swift I just can't
tell you how much I've thought about it
it's so weird it's [ __ ] weird how
much a political of like a political
stance can divide your fans like
somebody I was talking about guns and
[ __ ] and somebody was like I mean every
time I tweet and it's not that to me
that's not even a political thing like
if just people are dying you got to fix
the situation and people to like stay
out of politics comedian and I'm just
like I can't I don't know how to I don't
know how to do it you know I just
whatever I responded to some guy was
like I'm the if you think being
political me talking about people dying
as being political then I'm the goddamn
vice president because you're goddamn
right I'm political and so I but but the
[ __ ] the Kid Rock thing is just such
a
mess it's weird this is like a guy like
me who doesn't know [ __ ] about Kid Rock
like would be if if I didn't know
anything about him like I don't care
like I don't care if you think that all
Americans need guns I don't think that
that there should be automatic weapons
for sale to civilians also here's the
other thing too when people are like
yeah well the government you know this
rules put in place for the government
can up dude the government can do kiya
you think you're gonna hold off the
government with an assault rifle
they got nukes you know what that would
also they have more people did oh oh
yeah dude hey [ __ ] keep your yeah
keep the government away of your from
your [ __ ] townhouse with an ak-47 and
32 bullets but you know what the
government has more people dude the
[ __ ] crash a tank through your
townhouse and you know it like what are
you talking about yeah well I'm here for
when the government tries to take over
it already took over they've got so many
people so that's a weirdest [ __ ]
argument for me that being said you know
security have a guy with a gun in the
[ __ ] Walmart protecting everyone to
have that [ __ ] I don't you know what
it's like that guy who [ __ ] the other
day who held the other guy at bay
because he was security and he had a gun
and he was holding the guy and who
brought in as an assault right a rifle -
I don't know where it was you remember
something like 7-eleven or [ __ ] those
but he held him good good good good dude
have armed guards around I don't give a
[ __ ] but like I saw that picture of a
guy who had a the [ __ ] assault rifle
and he was like in line at a coffee bean
like
hood leave it in the car somebody was
like would you be more scared or less
scared if you saw this guy in the in the
coffee bean because you know that he
could protect hey God the guy had
[ __ ] jeans on you know if you weren't
jeans don't have an assault rifle dude
wear camo and be in the government or
army it's so weird to be like in line
with an assault rifle over your back and
you're just like yeah let me get uh
anything oh you got chai yeah don't come
to me for political views to like if
you're [ __ ] straight up like well
dude lost a podcast fan alright okay you
know side of the [ __ ] era dude I told
you silly goose time period but yeah
this hilarious are getting rid of video
games and that movie the hunt they
cancelled that [ __ ] crazy they cancelled
that [ __ ] Universal canceled the movie
the hunt it was gonna be out put up and
ring it up in here it was gonna be out
and they just [ __ ] gone just gone
because of how I guess Universal cancels
the hunt release Universal Pictures
scroll up Universal Pictures cancel the
release of his upcoming thriller the
hunt the film's producers previously set
to hit theaters September 27th when
Universal Pictures had already paused
the marketing campaign for the hunt
after thoughtful consideration I get
that the studio has decided to cancel
our plans to release the film
a spokesperson for Universal set in the
in a statement we stand by our
filmmakers and will continue to
distribute films in partnership with the
bold and visionary creators like those
now is not the time to release this film
they're not gonna release it that's the
thing dude you know on one hand it's
like sensor you know I get I get being
like sensitive and [ __ ] but also that
censorship it really is because Trump
was saying you know I loved the tweet to
that Trump did was just a mess about it
he was just like What did he say let me
look it up here I'm pissed I'm pissed
I'm pissed I can't get the code in I'm
pissed all good I can't get my code in
uh What did he say
yeah he chummy he did but he didn't say
the tunt in it dude he [ __ ] tweets so
much dude liberal Hollywood is racist at
the highest level okay and with great
anger and hate they'd like to call
themselves elite but they're not elite
now this is weird cuz like I'm in
Hollywood and I've never heard someone
in Hollywood be like you know I'm elite
they do
yeah they exactly they say that you know
people are only saying the Hollywood
elite when they're making fun of
Hollywood like nobody thinks they're
elite like who thinks they're elite
unless you're like a [ __ ] soldier
that went through training
you're not elite cuz you were in [ __ ]
what's that movie with Milo Ventimiglia
and the dog
you're not elite cuz you're [ __ ]
Jenna Elfman you know you just in them
in some [ __ ] elite but he's right they
like to call themselves elite but they
are not elite in fact it is off imagine
me thinking I'm elite cuz I was in the
show Whitney well you know I'm a leak
because I was in an episode of
workaholics and undateable in fact it is
often the people that they strongly
oppose that are actually the elite okay
so now he's calling himself elite the
movie coming out is made in order to
inflame and cause chaos they create
their own violence
and then try to blame others they are
the true racists and very bad for our
country
I like how basic he gets sometimes
they're very bad for our country like
it's like like he's learning about it
like he just figured it out they are
true the true racist I don't understand
he tweets a mess I don't understand how
he's saying it's there that that makes
them the true racists it doesn't have
anything to do with race okay speaking
of which did you see what Biden said
about the [ __ ] that what a get what a
[ __ ] mess that was dude he I don't
think that he I don't know if he'll hold
it together man could he look more like
a [ __ ] pilot that like doesn't fly
anymore poor kids are just as bright as
white kids ah major mistake I mean just
a major mistake imagine being up there
saying that and then knowing you [ __ ]
up he tried to make it better to which
was the best afterwards he goes like
this poor kids are just as smart and
talented as white kids and then he goes
and black kids and age and whatever i
tooted runs away and the massages are
girls shoulders real quick I don't know
why I didn't do it I don't know I mean I
don't I don't know I'm not about
anybody's policies because I'm a [ __ ]
ignoramus but that [ __ ] was like oh I
mean dude that's so [ __ ] it's crazy
yeah that's the kind of thing that can
ruin you you know after that you think
it's done he's just he's just [ __ ] up
too much um he just [ __ ] up too much I
don't know if he'd be good or bad but I
did like how he went bingo though that's
my favorite thing that any politician is
of
done cuz every politician is like well
you know we don't want to do this but we
do want to do that and so it's not a yes
or no question but they were like so you
want to take a take away assault rifles
bingo like this [ __ ] like had a hard
dick when he said it I love that
that's hilarious to me I just love I
kind of don't even care what you believe
in I love you got a the way you believe
in it is the best like but yeah Kid Rock
dude
when Kid Rock said the thing about about
about Taylor Swift that's a mess too
Taylor Swift wants to be a Democrat
because she wants to be in movies period
and it looks like she will suck the
doorknob off Hollyweird to get their
oldest move in the book good luck girl
Kid Rock hey kid Rock you don't have to
sign your tweet know why it says Oh
twice above the tweet your name it says
kid rock at Kid Rock Taylor Swift once
we don't get blah blah good luck girl
Kid Rock Republicans love to sign the
[ __ ] out of their tweet like it's a
letter like they did some [ __ ]
sincerely Kid Rock also Kid Rock is your
name you know don't sign off on anything
cuz your name is Kid Rock
so funny dude also suck the doorknob off
Holly weird dude Holly weird sucks when
people say that are you a [ __ ] 15
year old chick on vacation Holly weird
what a [ __ ] weird [ __ ] you know
Holly weird suck the doorknob
like just say dicks imagine thinking man
like what did I tweeted about it I think
and I wrote it what did I say just
imagine being like dude I can't get over
the fact go down right there no down
down where is it how many times I
goddamn tweet the other day I can't
think about how weird Kid Rock sweet was
of all the things you mental you mad
that tell us was Emma crap but then I
realized this it's it's better than that
he thinks she's trying to get into
movies by pretending she's a a Democrat
dude like imagine her thought process
she's like god I really want to do
movies I bet I could get cats if I went
blue she's the biggest [ __ ] singer in
the world
also somebody tweeted after that they
were like hey Kid Rock are you jealous
Taylor Swift as in cats
that's so funny to think about Kid Rock
being like oh like - watching the cat's
trailer and then having him be like oh
oh they made this movie without me like
and then saw Taylor Swift in it and then
just is up in arms like what the [ __ ]
they call me Kid Rock why are you mad I
guess cuz that's the thing when when
somebody says who's got a huge fanbase
is like okay well [ __ ] this
[Music]
you know now I got to speak out like you
could just lose a lot of fans I guess
that's my favorite when people are just
like well okay I bought your last album
it's the last album of yours I buy like
Taylor Swift could give a [ __ ] you know
the art of racing in the rain that's
what it is
what a [ __ ] ass name for that for that
[ __ ] ass book if I like there isn't a
book that would be in the airport more
than the art of racing in the rain did
they sell those exclusively at Hudson
news that [ __ ] name is such a cuck
name dude I mean either a woman wrote it
this is the only thing or a guy oh oh
okay his name is Garth that makes sense
there you go there you go
a guy named Garth wrote that book the
art of racing in the rain the art not an
art oh you mean racing it's just racing
called the book racing god that's so
pretentious dude the art of racing in
the rain starring a dog I like Milo
Ventimiglia though I [ __ ] like that
dude that dude like is ripped and he's
just he's like a man and he's in that
movie but he's like not to like he's
just gotta know I met him once or twice
and I just like that dude and I'm happy
he's got success on that movie her show
what is it
once this is us or whatever the [ __ ] and
everyone says I look like I'm in stuff
so I guess I have to like him it's so
funny that people like people who
secretly look like them
that's always that that's so funny like
bald dudes [ __ ] at the gym love the
rock and Jason Statham that's just how
they are you got oh you have to [ __ ]
that guy you never hear a bald guy say
[ __ ] that guy about the rock like you'll
never hear that nah not for me man nah
he represents you you know what I'm
saying is Milo Ventimiglia you represent
me yeah anyway I'm [ __ ] cold too okay
I'm [ __ ] cold - dude I wore a [ __ ]
cool shirt the other day and everyone
was like what and they looked at me a
little longer and I've got a tan dude so
people were like kind of impressed I
walked into the Laugh Factory I saw
people the way they looked at me like
friends of mine they looked at me and I
saw some of them look at me like haters
that's how I know I looked good I had
[ __ ] tan I was a tan on I had my
shirt unbuttoned a little bit so the
chest hair was peeking out like somebody
was [ __ ] peering out of a bush that's
what it looked like my chest hair was
cool and I smiled a lot and the shirt
was nice dude it was like felt good
people thought all right Brent Morin
goes like this all you used to make fun
of me for wearing stuff like that and I
said yeah I know because it wasn't in
then and it is now gentle slam but
whatever gentle [ __ ] slam I just
tucked him away talked him in bed and
just went good night night buddy
I gotta start saying night-night buddy
after I slam somebody dude you used to
make fun of me for wearing stuff like
that yeah because it wasn't in when you
did it and now it is night-night buddy
and then just walk onstage and just
[ __ ] bang bang any Danny Nate Lenalee
Oh what was I saying oh yeah ads here we
go baby blue apron dude I love blue
apron man it feels it tastes so good in
your mouth this season experienced the
joy of cooking something new and making
dinner fun with blue apron check out
summer menu and try customer favorite
burger recipes with the beyond burger
you've heard about the plant-based
burger phenomenon now give it a try blue
apron supplies the recipe you do the
cooking and the result is truly beyond
and I've had to be on burger and they're
very good if you haven't you got to try
them it's very interesting how much they
taste like actual meat burgers they
helped me discover my inner chef blue
apron does so you can learn new Epis new
recipes and techniques not episodes
because it's cooking upcoming meals
include caramelized onion and cheddar
those are three things that are amazing
caramelized onion and also cheddar cajun
shrimp and corn pancakes you kidding me
seared pork chops and peach salsa la
yellow tomato and zucchini pasta okay to
start making delicious brag worthy meals
at home without the hassle try blue
apron check out this week's menu and get
$60 off when you visit blue apron calm
slash Congrats that's blue apron calm /
Congrats blue apron a better way to cook
equip the easiest way to ease back into
a routine started up before September
especially if you're headed back to
school right
simplify the morning and evenings now
with a simpler electric toothbrush from
clip time sonic vibrations cover the
basics of every part of your mouth and
just take two minutes twice a day the
mirror mount puts brushing front and
center in your bathroom so you'll
remember to bookend the day using your
new brush add the lightweight compact
design and the lightweight compact
design means that you can bring it along
with you those last summer weekend
getaways sensitive sonic vibrations and
for kids the new brush is the same as
our original version parrots you get
this for your kids they like brushing it
with this it's very cool it looks cool
tweaked for sized down mouths
kids are inspired to brush better and
more often with oral care that looks and
feels like the products the adults in
their life use is very cute so you want
to be cute you get quit brush heads are
automatically delivered on a dentist
recommended schedule every three months
for just five dollars you probably like
well okay that's cool but it's all gonna
cost me twenty grand no five dollars a
friendly reminder when it's time to
refresh and to stay committed to your
oral health seventy-five percent of us
use old worn-out bristles that are
ineffective there you go you're gonna
have bad teeth so get quit and you won't
have bad teeth Equipe is great for
keeping me in my routine at home and on
the road that's why I love clip and why
it's perfect for getting back into a
routine clip starts at just 25 dollars
and if you go to get clip calm slash
Congrats right now you can get your
first repo backpack free
that's your first refill pack free at GE
tqu yp.com / congrats anyway dude we got
to make money so that's why we do ads if
if I wasn't able to do ads I wouldn't do
this podcast a lot of people will be
like oh so oh so you didn't do ads huh
sellout that's the whole goal baby
selling out when you go and you do a
theater show are you trying to sell half
the seats are you trying to sell out
that's right
[Laughter]
this was great when I tweeted this what
not did the tweet wasn't great but when
people got mad I wrote do you have the
rewards app no would you like to get it
no are you a member no do you want to be
for special no would you like a receipt
give me my [ __ ] [ __ ] and let me leave
like that's like every place you go to
is like hey would you like it think no
you better know did you want it no okay
can I have my [ __ ] doughnut or what's
what's the deal here
P and then somebody writes to me people
are just doing their job and what
they're told to do point us at general
energy at companies not the human making
crap pay who doesn't even want to ask in
the first place i rep point your garbage
energy at someone who isn't a comedian
now I'm not making a joke and then they
put another person writes jokes are
supposed to be funny and I wrote I
wonder if there might be a better chance
that you just may have a bad sense of
humor
now night-night buddy night-night buddy
I didn't know there were beds in Denny's
sorry dude
I'm not in my waiter uniform but here's
an all-american grand slam night-night
buddy you shouldn't eat so close to
bedtime because it'll give you bad
dreams or restless leg syndrome however
here we are I went to I by the way I
can't eat that's it i canti before bed
that's it I'm old yes [ __ ] yeah it's
only pretty much gray on one side of my
beard yes I don't do I think do I not
like it because it's asymmetrical yes I
don't like it would I rather it be very
symmetrical no would I rather be kind of
so much boy yes if it's very symmetrical
when people have [ __ ] very
symmetrical gray hairs on their [ __ ]
cheeks does it look like they dyed it
and then do they look like a [ __ ] yes
but do I only wonder don't want sound
like I have it not really but do I get
to change it yes if I dyed it would I
change it no because that means I'm a
[ __ ] come on
dye your beard who
you Bryan Callen I would down my beard
though if I had to do it for a show I
would um but whatever dude you know we
all still squirt well we don't all still
score q no I mean I got a [ __ ] yeah
but so just don't don't ever take what I
say seriously on Twitter or really
anybody really you know unless you're a
[ __ ] hate monger which I'm not
the my bookie
listen it's a new season Antonio Brown
is on the Raiders
Livan ball is on the Levon Bell is with
the Jets
I don't know sports Odell Beckham is in
Cleveland I know but Adele Beckham and
he's in Cleveland and that's crazy to me
but it's wild but the one thing that
hasn't changed where I'm putting my
money down on all the games and I've
done this my bookie is the place to bet
on football every weekend my bookie has
better bonuses and more prop bets than
any other sports book period this year
they're hosting the first online
handicap super contest first place is
guaranteed to win at least 100,000 and
it only costs $100 to enter so you want
to be a thousandaire put that hundred
dollars down all you got to do is pick
five NFL games against the spread every
week to climb the leaderboard and score
your share of the huge cash prize pool
that's why my bookie is always the right
play you bet you win they pay live in
game betting on and if every NFL game
it's awesome up to $1,000 first deposit
bonus double your first deposit use
promo code Congrats to activate the
offer visit my bookie doc my bookie vit
let me say that again so I don't mess it
up use promo code Congrats to activate
the offer visit my bookie online today
it's my bo o ki e and don't forget to
use the promo code congrats co ng R 80s
and when creating your account to claim
the bonus that win get paid
better help is there something
interfering with your happiness or is
preventing you from achieving your goals
you know I mean sometimes I have like
anxiety that that gets in the way of me
doing what I need to do and all that
stuff but introducing better help it
will assess your needs and match you
with your own licensed professional
therapist you can start communicating in
under 24 hours it's not a crisis line
it's not self-help it is professional
counseling done securely online it's
good for people and it's you know it's
sometimes you need this and you can't
get a quick appointment but you can hear
there is a broad range of expertise in
better helps counselor network which may
not be locally available in many areas
it's available for clients worldwide you
can log into your account anytime and
send a message to your counselor you'll
get timely and thoughtful responses plus
you can schedule weekly video or phone
sessions so you won't ever have to sit
and uncomfortable waiting room and you
can chat and text with your therapist
even between sessions visit better help
calm / Congrats and join the over
500,000 people talking taking charge of
their mental health with the help of an
experienced professional
congratulations listeners get 10% off
your first month at better help calm /
congrats congratulations is brought to
you by cash app the official app of the
log cabin I almost went in the hole I I
I was
that's it that's for you guys dude I did
that for you guys respect I don't you
know you just listen to a fart noise
dude that's part of your day you listen
to a [ __ ] 39 year old do a fart noise
and you did it four times I love my life
and that's it I love it
I've orchestrated it to be the way that
I want to yay you should too it's hard
though you know I mean I know I've been
given [ __ ] certain opportunities that
you know look there's a whole [ __ ]
some people are luckier than others and
it's hard life is harder for you know
for some people but you can do it um I
think it's so funny when people get mad
at what's her name Kylie is it Kylie
Jenner for saying she's a self-made
billionaire and people are like Hello
self-made wasn't she born into money did
you see Travis Scott Scott put all those
[ __ ] flowers goddamn [ __ ] you know
Travis Scott filled Kylie Jenner's house
with roses for her birthday and it's
just [ __ ] covered it's a sea of roses
in her house or in their house and it
and dude hey let me tell you right now
dude Travis Scott had nothing to do with
it Travis Scott goes like this pickup
even call he just texted hey can you
cover the whole house with roses for
college birthday and then the assistant
goes yes and that's all that Travis
Scott did the black like he's so
romantic this [ __ ] ain't romantic you
taxed it i text all day long it must be
the most romantic [ __ ] also what
a waste
also how funny is it that like literally
she put a video of it up and then all of
her assistants cleaned it up the
assistants should just start [ __ ]
each other they're doing the middle work
just
cut out the middleman and start [ __ ]
Hey
kylie jenner's assistant [ __ ] Travis
Scouts assistant stop doing all this
[ __ ] you're trying to get some
[ __ ] puss
what are you doing dude covering floors
with rose petals hey just do the
horizontal mambo and we out if you don't
call sex the horizontal mambo honestly I
want nothing to do with you dude where's
that even from the horizontal mambo I
heard somebody say that once that's it
dude
that was it for me that day I went to
sleep I think it was [ __ ] 2:30 p.m. I
went this bed right after that I go like
this good night it's got to be a new day
after that cuz that [ __ ] was the best
thing that was gonna happen all day huh
no no way no it was like a [ __ ] it
had to be a thing yeah so Chris Rock
should cover Taylor Swift's floor with
roses to say sorry what'd I say Oh Kid
Rock yet Chris Rock I said nah [ __ ] that
Chris Rock should do it worst impression
of all time I can't do a [ __ ] I can't
do a lot of impressions so it's all good
dude
do you really need to do impressions you
know got a hang now dude lots of stuffs
going wrong off [ __ ] yeah dude got a
hangnail fan didn't work lips are
chapped are you still listening anyway
right now am I talking to no one it
would be amazing if this podcast like
everyone just stopped listening at this
point I was literally just doing like a
[ __ ] suicide note nobody listened oh
and guess what the [ __ ] microphones
going down yes what a sinking ship this
forecast is you watch this cuz it's a
sinking ship that's why you watch it um
but whatever
I think we're getting more views than
[ __ ] Theo so I'm happy
uh I don't know what else dude you know
we can [ __ ] talk about whatever the
[ __ ] you want but you can't talk back
Kenya so it's all good you guys have a
bucket list dude don't do that just do
what you want all the time
there's no bucket list before I die
what's this hole before I die [ __ ] just
go do it
people make everything way more dramatic
than it needs to be
I got a bungee jump that's on my bucket
list just [ __ ] go why are you
mentioning death that's like when
[ __ ] chicks on Instagram or like
uh-uh take me back just [ __ ] go dude
what do you mean take me back to this
[ __ ] Hut go who's stopping you or
they the picture where the girls got the
hand and she's take good take it go take
me to go hold my hair take it go just go
walk walk walk walk walk I guess it's a
famous thing that started with one
couple oh dude it's so pretentious when
people don't show their face and stuff
[Laughter]
think they're being all real when
they're like it but it's not about and
they don't show their face like they're
[ __ ] masta killa from the wu-tang
masta killa you know that was the guy
who didn't show his face on the wu-tang
wu-tang names dude inspect that deck you
know no there's his face I guess I was
wrong about that master killer who's the
wu-tang guy that never showed his face I
think it was a master killer and then
who's the guy the wu-tang clan Matt oh
and you Google would take angle with the
wrong thing goo
he grew this how [ __ ] want farías he
googled the wu-tang mask you know what's
gonna come up one of those [ __ ]
things that people that Asian people
wear in the airports buyer agent was so
concerned with like wearing those things
in it would well why is that an Asian
thing what are they worried about bird
flu it's racist
um I mean Jesus whatever dude it's not
ghost face we all look ghost faces
Google ghost face anyway back to the
hand thing he just said straight up gave
up and went back to the game they it
doesn't matter we move her back on the
hand thing yeah but like when just
people are when people are just [ __ ]
trying to make [ __ ] more dramatic that's
the [ __ ] that I that's the [ __ ] that it
that's that [ __ ] I don't like
I think we have that on the soundboard
like I could just say that I don't know
why that's on the soundboard but we know
why the we know is fine anyway dude I
think I'm just trying to really do all
this to be a [ __ ] inspirational Tony
Robbins type guy I want to do I want to
be a call I am a cult leader for this
thank you very much for being in my cult
and also we need to build the log cabin
at some point and when you a lot of you
guys come up to me I chose and you're
like just waiting for that log cabin I'm
here to help that [ __ ] makes me feel
good you know because like that's that's
awesome that I have like people that are
willing to help put boards up and like
floors and like sit in tall grass with
me but yeah what are you doing what are
you guys doing are you got work are you
[ __ ] I'm with you dude I'm in your ear
and I'm with you I want you to know that
I want you to know that even though you
can't talk back I'm with you right now
and we're talking you're in your head
and I but guess what I'm in your head
too so this is a conversation when I do
my podcast and when I'm talking I want
you guys to also be going like this when
I'm talking yeah yeah I don't know I
want you to be doing that in your
like even now if you don't agree with
this I want you to be like I don't know
yeah I guess Chris and I also let's try
it honestly you know what [ __ ] let's
do this you you say are pretty good I'm
gonna say hey how you doing you say I'm
pretty good do it out loud at work hey
how you doing and I want to know how
that felt dude we're talking I'm losing
my [ __ ] mind I don't you know I
that's the goal though is to be crazy
people act like it's sad when old people
lose their minds get the [ __ ] out of
here I want my brain I want there to be
a day literally from my brain and it
just I hear it I want to hear my brain
go and I go like you know I just want my
brain to be like and I just go Toyota or
some [ __ ] like lose my mind and some of
the guys like why did he just say
[ __ ] Toyota and I just start walking
backwards forever you don't you don't
want to be too crazy you want to be that
[ __ ] nice sweet spot crazy you want
to be you don't want to be too crazy
because that [ __ ] look stressful man
like if you're just like ah oh you see
guys are just like you're like that's
tense dude all your muscles are working
you want to be that kind of crazy where
you're just like yeah I don't give a
[ __ ] about stuff man because you know
we're all gonna die the end of the
world's coming hangout was [ __ ]
brutal dude it's the size of my [ __ ] do
you want to do should we do anything
like questions okay let's do questions I
just like to picture on Instagram
that's our respectful I am yeah so we're
gonna so we take some questions and we
just cut because I just wanted to go
find some questions but I don't care so
this guy Billabong chena
change it of course change billabong and
Chino
remember Chino XL the [ __ ] rapper he
made a song called Chien our dough
DiCaprio ah trying so hard she and
nodded to Cappy oh wow it's so funny -
I'm gonna play a little bit of it Nardo
I mean how do you even dick cap Chia
DiNardo what was his name
well Chino XL oh because he's Chino XL
dick cap Bri oh there we go
she no exhale chin order DiCaprio course
dude
[Music]
he still lifestyle what she in order to
Caprio anyway go back to the guy Chris
Leah inspired me to go hardest [ __ ]
the gym down ten pounds in three weeks
babies let's make it a great Thursday
that's this [ __ ] I like dude because
he's making himself healthier and and
babies let's make it a great Thursday
it's a community bro it's a community
man and we're bettering ourselves and
some of us get cancer and die but the
others we're all bettering ourselves man
that's awesome that's a sweaty [ __ ]
guy at the gym do it because he's
killing it not some people just go to
the gym to do a social event bro not me
the tips of my hair look you know sweaty
that's great dude congrats ray room I
mean he's [ __ ] Billabong Chino at Ray
Romano yo like just what's his real
thing man
who you met masa killer from okay all
right Kyle Potter there you go at Kate
Potter 15 good congratulations
help oh you know what he brought up it's
not [ __ ] at all actually this guy
doesn't know what how [ __ ] is how [ __ ]
is at the star receiver and Tony bird on
my red traffic cameras all that is not
[ __ ] at all you don't understand what
[ __ ] now listen that makes you want
to talk about it though that is
legitimately my favorite thing that's
happened to all month that Antonio Brown
Antonio Brown said he won't bro it's so
funny
see this is what I was just talking
about about I don't care what you
believe but I care how you believe it he
said I guess they changed the rules on
the helmets I don't know why probably a
money thing even though they're
pretending like it's a safety thing but
he says no football without wide
receiver in Turner Bert Brown has told
the Oakland Raiders he will not play
football again unless he can wear his
old helmet leave sources told ESPN on
Friday run had a two-hour conference
call with an independent arbitrator on
Fridays
that to argue why he should be allowed
to wear his ten-year-old helmet he is
thought to have been using the same
helmet his whole career the arbitrator
for the grievance call was joined by
league officials play representatives
yada-yada-yada Brown wants to wear the
helmet he prefers not one of the newer
model helmets that League rules mandate
league sources said Brown believes that
the new believes the new certified
helmet protrudes out and interferes with
his vision as he tries to catch a
football
now that's an actual legit grievance
okay but this is just it's just great
the way he the Raiders have been sending
Brown other approved helmets to wear but
at this time he is not interested in
wearing any of them
that's [ __ ] hysterical okay that he
takes the helmets puts them on and goes
nope not that one and keeps putting on
helmets nope not that one Brown appeared
to refer to an internal debate about
walking away from the football by
posting Friday and Instagram caption
paraphrasing the to painful I don't know
something made me laugh here he just
like they keep like okay yeah this is
what I read is that he keeps they keep
sending him [ __ ] things football
helmets and he keeps thinking he doesn't
like them and then he eventually got fed
up and said you know what I'm gonna wear
the old one err I quit dude that's so
talked about [ __ ] that's so dope
that's hilarious
don't wanna any time an adult reaches
that don't want a level I'm in I'm in
dude you're invited to the log cabin
Antonio Brown don't wanna that's so dope
to be that much of a child as an adult
that's what I want that's what I am
don't wanna but six million dollars next
year can I wear the helmet
no keep it don't wanna I did prove with
my pants that's so funny to me I love
him now I'm a big fan of him don't even
know what it looks like don't care okay
I'm gonna [ __ ] I want to go out on a
date with them straight up a
heterosexual midday date where we go and
we see the art of racing in the rain and
we just chill he popped one I'll pay for
all of the [ __ ]
or he could pay for a female is more
comfortable I'll be the girl kind of or
the like whatever doesn't have to be
about gender but I could be the you know
the lesser one not that girls are lesser
but you know what I mean
not that guys I said but you know I
Mane's like Ricky Gervais the one who
takes it is what I mean in that whole
exchange the one who gets [ __ ] is
obviously the less powerful one is all
I'm saying
I guess I've never run for [ __ ]
president but you know what though I am
the president so kiss my ass what's the
next one
someone Alexis at arc writing someone
showed me one clip of Chris Thalia on
Facebook and now I've seen both Netflix
specials his first we feast hot ones
interview and his h3 podcast interviews
and I'm 15 episodes deep in a
congratulations pot and can't stop
listening listening as they tweet
actually well let me tell you Alexis you
got a long way to go and to listening to
these episodes and your Kurt your great
your walk you're welcome you are welcome
dude you are welcome to the to this
[ __ ] thing here thank you very much
for listening and I think that that's
great and that's what that's what we do
here we share the [ __ ] podcast we
share the ideas we are a cult we are a
[ __ ] cult we were all blue aims at
Ryan aims 1 2 3 how [ __ ] is it for a
person who works outside to call their
outdoor workplace the office well yeah
of course it is an office has walls
period that's it if you don't have a
walls you're outside
is there a printer out there no not an
office
you know there's a crew come in and
clean that area maybe if it's outside
maybe not though
offices indoors I guess we're done here
you know that's it I wanted to answer
some questions there we go that's very
cool
download the cash app for free on the
App Store or Google Play market you can
download my app to Chris D'Elia type
that in I'll be in you know other areas
and stuff Houston I'm coming for you go
to crystal Viacom San Diego or as my mom
says for no reason yeah San Diego just
cuz she wants to say it not because she
thinks it's that just because she wants
to be silly she's cute but do you want
that she dressed like a [ __ ] kung fu
master sometimes yeah this gym when moms
when white moms turned like 65 they
start dressing like kung-fu masters and
you know that and that's all I have to
say about that they wear [ __ ] pants
and shirt that are the same and they're
a little bit shiny and then they have
those [ __ ] weird buttons that are
long that go in the other [ __ ] out
the hole that comes out like the string
and they tuck it in and they do that and
they look like they could [ __ ]
absolutely kill other other Kung Fu
people God if what if my mom was in a
[ __ ] kung fu movie did I got to make
that movie what if there was a movie
where a mom was a kung fu master but
like an old mom that wasn't good at kung
fu and they taught her kung fu and then
they did a movie and it would be so
funny but my mom can barely walk up a
hill without hurting her planners
fasciitis so I don't think that'll be in
the cards anyway um take pictures of
your mom and tweet them to me and make
it I want to prove to you that they look
like they'd [ __ ] do kung fu
all right I'm done you guys are great
remember support the show you can buy
the merch I got this shirt this is the
new one features to bright show people
how your futures you got what you got to
[ __ ] put your sunglasses on all week
to put your site so guys on all guy then
we go kill it man
because remember life rips lever ups and
you know that's it I guess that's it
thanks so much
[Music]